live vocal now a woman who is having a
difficult time paying for her husband's
funeral expenses is very thankful
tonight her husband charles wade jr was
a vietnam veteran he was actually hit
and killed while crossing tropicana near
torrey pines a little bit over a week
ago joe muller spoke to her as she
received some much needed help today and
he joins us now in studio with an update
yeah if you have buried a loved one you
know just how expensive this can be
anita wade was having a difficult time
getting the money together to start
paying for the expenses that was until
today
we would like to present you
[Applause]
with a check
for the past week anita wade was worried
about how she would pay for her
husband's funeral he was in the united
states for rings charles wade jr was
also a purple heart vietnam veteran he
was shot really bad he was in the
hospital
for
well i think a little over three years
he died yards away from their apartment
i shared her story about her struggles
trying to come up with the money to
start charles's funeral process when i
was reading on the news app about how
she lost her husband and her husband was
a vietnam veteran
and you know things are tough right now
it really moved me neil sagmari owns
nevada coin mart a business not too far
from where the crash happened he wrote a
check to the funeral home for two
thousand dollars to get this process
started we appreciate your husband and
his service one of the things that i
pride myself on and my business on is
that we are here to help the community
thank you so much that's exactly what i
need for the down payment anita says she
wouldn't know what to do without this
help this is a huge start this is my
only start right now sag mary hopes this
leads to other good deeds throughout las
vegas it's about helping the community
and trying to do anything that we can
for them
wade was not in a designated crosswalk
that night however jalen thomas was
arrested for leaving the scene and dui
related charges he was in court today
posted bail and is being electronically
monitored
so joe what about the va a lot of times
when they hear about these things they
might be able to help i mean just can
they help her with these expenses yeah
she has been in talks with the va she
already called them to get this all set
up and she tells us that the va will
actually cover about two thousand
dollars of it and we'll reimburse her so
as you know this might cost much more
than that so this is a good start yeah
nice to hear the community coming to
help her for sure all right joe thanks
for that update